it is so nice to see the four of you
cnco all together you know you were
together for seven years and now it's
time to go on a new journey how has
everything been for you guys it's been
crazy pretty amazing it's pretty it's
been uh it's been like a roller coaster
of emotions to be honest um
but at the end of the day we feel we
feel really
positive of this of what we're doing
right now we feel like it's the right
move we feel like
uh the other day we all gonna make it i
feel a hundred percent that so
of course you are we're we're como
uh you're calm
in peace
yes
zombie i see you smiling big how are you
feeling about this next chapter i feel
great i mean we feel great um
it's like a mix of emotions because
you know we we've been so we've been
together so many years and the only way
we we know the the industry is together
you know
um but it's at the same time it's super
exciting like start something new and
start a new project project
um so
i don't know kind of excited honestly
eric
tell me did you think that this was
always the plan was it was it the plan
to make history with cnco and then
go off on your individual directions
yeah for sure since like the first
minute i mean we work um to be like the
best you know we like um dream
super
big big um since the beginning and we
knew also that um every band you know
half an end because that's like you know
the normal yeah that's life that's yeah
that's life exactly and richard you're
just straight up chilling you're wearing
your sunglasses you look like you're
just chilling how do you feel about this
are you at peace yeah exactly i'm just
chilling you know i'm kind of just um
enjoying the process you know i feel
like we're all just kind of just trying
to enjoy the process and and just you
know give the best energy throughout our
music and everything that's going to
happen you know at least till the day
comes you know but we have so much
things to do so um yeah man just enjoy
it i want to go back really quickly to
premier league chris you're on stage and
you said that you didn't have the words
you you really didn't know how to tell
the cnc owners that this was about
[Applause]
what was that day like were you nervous
about how they'd react a thousand
percent it was
to be honest when we said when we said
it it was like a big backpack like a
huge backpack just put it on the side
because it was like a big weight that we
had that night because we res we
received what we had the announcement of
the
of the
award before our presentation i think it
felt correct to do it there because it
was the award for best fandom and
and it was like a big spotlight so
we decided to do it there and then
everything happened you i think that
everything happens for a reason so yeah
that day i was so nervous that once like
somebody um say the announcement
i see the video and i'm laughing and i'm
like but this is supposed to be serious
so yeah i was like you know smiling for
like a reason
now that the announcement is out there
and fans have had like a month to sit
with the news how do you think your fans
are feeling it's been chilling i feel
like our fans um that's why we love our
friends you know i feel like they have a
good uh
sense of humor and they know how to also
take certain you know announcements and
stuff like that like this serious you
know and it's just been positive
reactions you know i feel like everybody
is kind of understanding where we're at
in our life you know and
and as you said you know that's life you
know it all has a beginning and an end
richard i want to ask you a question you
know i love getting updates on your
beautiful daughter aaliyah
now that you're all going in separate
directions does that mean that she gets
a little more time with dad at home is
that something that you're looking
forward to i hope so you know but i know
i have to work a lot so
um it's more about kind of like you know
finding that balance but i feel like now
i could like after this you know it's
gonna be a little bit more manageable my
time is going to be a little bit more
manageable you know yeah
i could spend time with her and stuff i
want to ask all of you if you can think
of one specific moment in cnco history
that you really felt the most proud
richard let's start with you when we
were nominated for the grammys i believe
that was like for me it was like
you know like an accomplishment yeah
even though we didn't get that grammy
but it was like just being a nomination
yeah hell yeah so and and we were just
young too like we were like five years
in or four years no even less i think it
was with the first time yeah so it was
crazy to like you know for me it was
like uh like a dream come true
and i didn't believe it in the beginning
but like now that i sit down and think
about it like you look back and i'm like
oh like we were nominated for granny and
we did all this stuff so super cool to
think about that i think a really
special moment was um in the mtv's um we
have you'll be amazed
when you're jumping on the cars
yeah yeah
the performance i think was one of like
the craziest and we got it
exactly exactly when we went to
asia
and
we see like people learning spanish to
be able to talk with us like our fans
you know like they was trying to learn
english so they can like have a
conversation with us and i think that's
what's really beautiful because
i don't know like be able to
share or culture that far is like
really crazy for me
i would say personally
i really loved when we
the first time we got in my country in
ecuador
when we literally step out of the
the airport
like literally the the when you get your
luggage and you just step out
we saw this massive amount of people
outside just waiting for us and it's my
country and everybody you know that was
like the first time that we kind of
raised god
such a big deal and i'm so so so excited
we've still got an album we've got a
tour we've got a disney plush show i
want to start with the album xoxo
[Music]
what was the inspiration for this album
richard it's more kind of to show that
you know that the stage that we're doing
the the creation creative stage that
we're in you know because this album was
you know mostly written by us and and
some of the songs were produced by uh
zab you know so so cool
yeah so it's cool to like kind of just
you know
show this stage to our fans and like
tell them hey look this is where we're
at now and we hope you guys enjoy and we
hope you guys take this this journey as
a celebration not as a you know um sad
or anything negative or whatever you
know so i think this this this album is
more for that for like to show the
celebration to like and also we have
more music coming out after this album
too so more music even after the album
yeah so that's like our last album and
we have more uh singles and featurings
and stuff like that coming out plus the
disney show uh music as well and stuff
like that it has a lot of soundtracks
that we wrote then we have the tour too
that we're prepping for next year and
yeah we'll see how it goes eric what is
the one song on xoxo that you're most
excited for the cnc owners to hear i'm
really excited for all of them um i
think
what is
more cool about this album is that um we
literally like work in every single song
of this album so i think it is like um
more personal um
with us but um i think
because like it's a song that we had for
a really
long time
um we have like two years with us and
and
that's the song that they produce by the
way
the production zombie i want to ask you
for any cnc owners out there as you guys
release all this fun new stuff what is
your message to them first of all thank
you for all this world is all these
years um
and also that
you guys are about to see the best
moment of cnco um we're gonna have a
disney show challenge um show show aha
disney show
um siri so
it's gonna be like a lot of content also
for you guys chris my final question for
you i feel like in entertainment there's
never really an end point you know
there's still so many opportunities to
do reunions to get back on stage
together even if you're pursuing
individual careers what do you say to
fans who are hoping that we might see
cnco together again someday
yeah a thousand percent like like how we
said this is
like we're just pursuing
something different
personally
but that doesn't mean that we're going
to
be enemies or something like that you
know like
yeah like we can we can still work right
together we can produce together we can
do so much things together and in the
future we see that that it could
could like
that we can do it in a proper way of
course we have we can do another show
another university or even as big as we
can do like something i don't know oh
[Music]